Rastafarians in South Africa celebrated
when the Supreme Court ruled that adults
may use marijuana and grew it for
personal consumption in private Jeremy
Acton had long campaigned for its
legalization takes a plant that was
forbidden ever since 1922 and puts it
back into the hands of the people to
cultivate and use in their personal life
so that's quite revolutionary it
completely overturned
about 90 years of oppression Parliament
now has two years to rewrite the laws
governing the use of marijuana champions
of weed or daca as it's called in South
Africa want to offer lawmakers their
input the government is coming in it as
newbies they don't understand the plant
they don't understand how best to make
these rules so we can really work with
them and hopefully come out with
something that will help South Africa
thrive activists point out that smoking
weed has been widespread in South Africa
for centuries and say homegrown cannabis
industry could promote economic growth
we want security in terms of food
clothes shelter health education and
welfare and we are saying that the
cannabis plant is going to assist us in
order to achieve all of those goals
sustainably and in the environmentally
friendly way those who use Daha are
happy but caution is still advisable
legal clarity is yet to be achieved
these anecdotal evidence to suggest that
police officer stole actually erased
people despite the fact that the court
nur has said now you can't just arrest
people for possession of a small amount
of cannabis that you are holding in
private but the question is what is
private yes your home is private your
garden is private but is your pockets of
your clothes private is your car private
we don't really know because the court
didn't give a legal definition of what
private would mean activists still have
a long way to go until Parliament sets
out the limits
you